michelle turner in the building we're
going to be on entertainment tonight
tonight catch us check i don't have any
kids and i'm sitting kind of close i
know you better back up
man i had so much fun on my pal nick
cannon's talk show today so he is
returning the favor indeed yes indeed
you had to come guest co-host ours by
the way nick cannon airs weekdays check
your local listings for where to tune in
do you love hosting a show like without
a teleprompter just kind of going that's
the beauty of having a daytime shot each
and every day you might not be having
the best day in in the world and you
still have to give the people what it is
and you got to let them know today
i got bubble guts today y'all you know
what i mean it's stuff like that to
where you know i i i love the
the intimacy but i love the spontaneity
of it as well because like anything can
happen live television oh yeah
hanging up my coat
man let me clear my throat we in here
okay so you have a segment on your show
i was watching when i was there called
what's popping what's popping so let's
get it popping all right let's get to it
you comment on the latest celebrity news
so i you know i'm going to ask you this
because you have history with both of
these folks okay kim kardashian and pete
davidson what do you make of i love them
both you okay do you love them together
i'm not mad at i mean obviously who am i
to judge when it comes to
about couples and who's dating who right
and sometimes you have opposites of
tracks sometimes you have synergies that
people may not know about but then also
when you have a character a charismatic
individual like a pete davidson who can
make people laugh like the dropper hat
like everybody loves to feel good
everybody loves to laugh who doesn't
want to be around a person andy cohen
andy cohen was a guest on your show
yesterday you played plead the fifth
with him apparently andy cohen has the
magic sauce to get people in trouble who
is your favorite baby mama
the next one
i'm witty i say funny thing okay
i was gonna say did every single one of
your baby mama say what do you mean the
next one everybody knows i'm crazy
everybody knows i say things that will
get me in trouble and at this point if
you're in my life and you don't know
like every day i'm gonna say something
out of pocket if you really don't know
me by the way okay i actually really did
like this you talked about it i know
you're being serious that you were going
to be a little more introspect you were
going to be celibate for the rest of
time
no i've actually been doing really
well uh i'm not controlled by an emotion
i'm not addicted to certain things that
sometimes you got to take a break i
always talk about this one of my biggest
insecurities and biggest fears is that
if i'm giving too much energy elsewhere
and not towards my children because i
have so many children so when i can kind
of cut out a certain aspect of my
lifestyle focus on children and work and
it makes it a lot easier so the holidays
are coming up right you have seven
children yes
i'm wondering how you handle christmas
shopping what do you do do you have you
have to have a plan holidays are scary
for me yes
i literally have to become
seven people santa claus
christmas eve i jump in my sleigh and i
get to get to getting across the country
well i know i had so much fun and your
show is a blast and you've got some
special stuff coming up i'm excited
because next week it's all my favorite
people that i love in music and you know
as a dj i have a wide range so yeah we
gonna see everybody from brian mcknight
to mc light and it's gonna be tight
all right listen she had this country
girl saying gotta who gotta have a word
[Music]